yeah the screen time thing when you look
at your screen time it's kind of like a
rude awakening where you're like
[ __ ] I said how much time looking at
this [ __ ] thing yeah yeah it's crazy
yeah and you know it's weird it's
because it's like you know my head is up
more
um I'm looking around more you know I
there's been times where
you know I would even see somebody's you
know a peer of mines a great video that
that they posted or whatever and I'm
like I'll call my guy right away like yo
we got to make something we like you
know and then that making something yeah
maybe would have pushed things a little
further or maybe not but in order to
make that I then would have to skip out
on dinner with my family where now I do
my work for the day I set my time and
then it's done and then I and then
whatever happens happens like whatever
it may be may be because I'm like you
know you only get one spin around this
planet so I'm like I'm like I don't
wanna the thing that I know you'll never
get back is time and especially you know
for those of us that have children I'm
like I'm never gonna get they'll never
be little again there will be a time
where they don't they don't want us yeah
they're gonna be like you're gross Go
away You're cringy yeah and I'm like
listen you got hot friends babe you know
like they're they're 19 right bring them
over yes I don't know no but but but
um so right now though I mean listen and
of course it's like you know you got to
work I'm happy to work my my career
makes me happy you know you got we have
to be happy first of course the rest of
our family's happy but I right now I'm
just like yeah man like I uh you know I
pick and choose what what it is I want
to do and and uh but the getting off
social media
um has helped me like tremendously I
genuinely in my heart believe that
whatever it is 50 years from now social
media will be looked at as toxic and
cancerous as smoking cigarettes were
back in the day like I think it's I
think it's a similar thing it's a
different thing it's not causing lung
cancer right but it is causing uh a
decay in society and I would have lost
the depression depression this I cannot
I would I would imagine I would be
willing to bet everything that suicide
rates being as high as they have ours is
directly linked to social media and I
think that the people at the social
media companies know that and I think
that it's you know it's it's an
algorithm it's they're feeding on our
our um social capabilities is it's money
to them so they they're they're they're
gambling on you know what we're gonna
are you know predicting our moves and
making money off it so I get it but I
don't want to be a part of it anymore
you know or as little that's dope man
yeah that's why I kill myself tonight
just blow my head off Jesus it's just